نبقى في العراق ولكن في ملف اخر فرغما
اعلان الانتصار قبل خمس سنوات على تنظيم
داعش الا ان الضربات التنظيم ما تزال
تستهدف العراقيين وتوقع قتلى وجرحى اعنف
هجمات التنظيم مؤخرا وقعت بقريه البوبالي
التي تقع على بعد سبعين كيلومترا شمال
بغداد حيث قتل عسكريون ومدنيون من ابناء
القريه وبحسب عقيد في الشرطه العراقيه
تحدث لوكاله الانباء الفرنسيه فان عناصر
داعش يختبئون في المناطق الريفيه
ويواصلون شلنا الهجمات بشكل متفرقه
ويشرحوا مقام قضاء الخالص حيث تقع
البوبالي ان المنطقه اصبحت منطقه عبور
للمتطرفين خاصه وان الحدود غير ممسوكه بين
محافظتي ديالا وصل صلاح وبحسب تقرير لمجلس
الامن الدولي نشر في يوليو من عام 2022
يملك التنظيم ما بين سته الاف الى 10
مقاتل منتشرين بين سوريا والعراق يتركزوا
معظمهم في المناطق الريفيه التحدي اذا ما
يزال قائما ويبدو ان على اجهزه الامن
العراقيه تدارك الامر سريعا منتظر الرشيد
من بغداد
قواتنا من العراق تعملوا على كبح نشاط
تنظيم داعش في المثلث الذي يربط محافظات
كركوك وصلاح الدين وديالا من خلال الاتي
رصد تحركات تنظيم داعش وتوجيه ضربات جويه
استباقيه الى مخابئه في المناطق البعيده
الاستعانه بكاميرات حراريه وطائرات مسيره
لمنع عناصر التنظيم من الاقتراب من القرى
والبلدات النائيه تجفيفه ما تبقى من مصادر
تمويل التنظيم داخل وخارج البلاد واخيرا
ضبط الحدود مع سوريا عبره اقامه جدار
وخنادقه مزوده بكاميرات حراريه
بعد الهزيمه انك راء التي الحقتها قواتنا
الامنيه البطله
بتنظيمات ارهابيه متمثله باداعش ارهابي
وبعدين كان وجودهم علنيا
وبعد الهزيمه اصبح وجودهم مخفيه
ويتمثل هذا الخفاء بالخلايا النائمه وهذا
وهذا يتطلب اييه جهود استخباري ساند الجهد
الميداني بعد انتهينا منه بعد خروج داعش
الظاهر يعني اكو ااه صائد النوع من
المشاكل على الحدود بيننا وبين سوريا
بنتمنى ان شاء الله من حكوماتنا انه تحاول
هل الموضوع عن طريق همم يعني تركيز على
الدعم اللوجستيو والاستخباري قواتنا
الامنيه وكذلك همم ممكن الاستعانه همم
هذه محافظات او هذه لتلك المناطق الحدوديه
يعني يجب توفير كافه
الاجهزه اللي ممكن انه تفيدنا بحمايه
الحدود اللي هي ممكن تكون كانها كاميرات
حراريه ممكن تكون
اجهزه انذار رادارات همم
اي اجهزه ممكن توفره ممكن نستفاد من الدول
المتطوره
الامكانيه
للقضاء على فلول داعش الارهابيه وباقي
المجانين يعني هذه ثانيا وضع قوات اضافيه
على الحدود
بين العراق والدول المجاوره للخلاص من
داعش الارهابيه